para empezar los diálogos con el eln el
gobierno primero debe darle al Estado
Mayor central un reconocimiento político
Perdón para comenzar los diálogos con
este grupo y dejarlo de tratar como un
grupo criminal en qué va ese proceso y
cuáles son las críticas que enfrenta por
otorgar dicho estatus
Hola María Clara Muchas gracias por la
invitación Pues en este momento el
Gobierno ya reconocido explícitamente al
Estado Mayor central como un grupo de
carácter político los retos tienen que
ver justamente que esta Estructura No es
un grupo propiamente unificado hay más
de 25 frentes dentro de lo que se
denomina Estado Mayor central y
justamente la suspensión de las órdenes
de captura les va a permitir reunirse Y
conformar eso que denominan Estado Mayor
central gran parte de las dudas tienen
que ver con si hay unidad de mando si
efectivamente son un interlocutor que
tenga unos criterios claros para
negociar ya tenemos una delegación
entonces en los próximos semanas o meses
Pues tendrá que definirse la delegación
de por parte del gobierno y un poco Cuál
va a ser el diseño del proceso su agenda
sus tiempos los lugares en los que se va
a desarrollar y el no ha firmado también
que quiere otorgarle el reconocimiento
político a la segunda marquetalia que es
la disidencia que fundaron Iván Márquez
y Jesús santrich antiguos negociadores
de las Farc en la Habana y quienes
retomaron las armas luego de firmar el
acuerdo pero Cuáles son las dificultades
jurídicas y políticas para que se dé ese
reconocimiento a la segunda marquetalia
gran parte de las de las dificultades en
términos jurídicos tienen que ver
también con las sentencias de la corte
que han señalado por ejemplo que los
delitos de narcotráfico y de secuestro
en los cuales han incurrido estas
disidencias no pueden ser delitos con
nexos en el marco de una negociación
política y por tanto no pueden ser
amnistiables sin embargo en últimas la
realidad es que el carácter político o
no que se le da a estos grupos Es una
decisión estratégica del presidente de
la república Pero además en un contexto
como el que tiene en este momento el
país y es que todos estos grupos están
en guerra entre sí tanto el eln con el
Estado Mayor central en zonas Como
arauca por ejemplo como el Estado Mayor
central con la disidencia de la segunda
marquetalia en zonas como el putumayo o
en zonas también como el cauca entonces
aquí hay un reto enorme que tiene que
ver con como estos diferentes procesos
de paz de alguna manera se relacionan
entre sí para posibilitar que haya una
disminución de la violencia y un alivio
del impacto humanitario